as we can tell the Sunday's Grammys were
already celebrating one winner
the Bandit maplewood Middle's news for
awesome he started off as just some
random kid I'm pretty sure nobody
thought he would be anything and now
look at him he's day at the grandmas
that he doesn't just want to keep his
like talent to himself he wants to share
with like everybody the band at
Maplewood Middle School in Sulphur
Louisiana is so popular about half the
students there are members only on CBS
this morning we're revealing that the
band's leader Mickey Smith jr. is the
winner of this year's Grammy music
educator award as part of our road to
the Grammys series Manuel Bojorquez
shows us why Smith put aside his own
musical aspirations to take teach
younger generations of musicians ready
for a music teacher Mickey Smith jr.
spends little time at the podium
[Music]
I'm moving around with them sometime
I'll sit down in the chair with them
because I always want to be cognizant of
what what did it feel like to be 12
because I believe if I am familiar with
that I can connect with them more and
that's really what it's all about
connection he remembers that age all too
well and growing up just about two miles
from here in Louisiana bayou country I
grew up on figuratively and literally
the other side of the tracks and a small
community called Mossville and it was a
small african-american community that
was formed by freed slaves and honestly
is no more now but it was there that a
friend got him interested in the school
band that is typically frugal
grandmother Lily Mae spent $400 on a
used saxophone and that his mother Emmer
tried to be supportive through those
first awful notes they were so bad in
fact my mom told me to keep on going
outside the house you got to practice
yeah down the driveway outside and then
across the street in the woods you got
good enough she let you back in the
house eventually they let me back in the
house looking back he says chasing that
perfect sound kept him from chasing the
temptations that befell other kids his
age and just listened to him now
you could have turned this into a music
career as a performer doing your own
thing why teach I was so rewarding why
not teach why not teach I think everyone
should have an opportunity to pour into
someone else
if you pour your cup empty I think comes
back twice as full but it wasn't always
the most popular class when he started
here 15 years ago there were only 28
students in the band now there are 146
that's half the school sixth graders
McKenzie Harmon and Kaitlin Rendon play
the flute so when you enrolled in the
middle school here did you know you
wanted to be part of the band never in
my life I thought I would but whenever I
saw the tryouts I thought maybe it would
be cool and next thing you know I loved
it so much he's amazing he makes things
funny super kind everyone
he gives us a chance he showed us
something that we didn't think that we'd
be able to do though eighth grader rave
on Washington plays clarinet there was a
star on the basketball team he initially
was hoping for something cooler I wanna
play a saxophone but didn't he was like
I think he did best in school and I was
like ah that's that's a bummer but you
know I realize you know actually trying
that's actually fun he credits mr. Smith
for changing him in many ways in sixth
grade I was like I shall make it and I
think I would be even worse even worse
going down the wrong direction yes like
very wrong direction but man has helped
me a lot and made me okay then maybe a
better person so take your pencil and
Mark that cuz it's confusing don't feel
bad
you've never seen this before Trayvon
was one of those students that I can say
I loved him just the way he was but I
loved him enough not to leave him just
the way he was and I believe that's what
teaching at its best and that's what
music can provide an opportunity for
growth an opportunity for trust in
honoring him with the Grammy music
educator award the Recording Academy
noted his ability to make students feel
loft valued and wanted of ultimately
helping them find their sound
I hope it means a change in their
perspective and understanding that
there's nothing I can't do that little
kid from a little town that doesn't even
exist anymore
on the other side of the tracks did it I
can do it too
for CBS this morning and while before
cos Sulphur Louisiana Mickey Smith jr.
is one wise man
all those kids tells you everything you
want to help jr. everybody should have
the opportunity to pour into someone
else yes so many little you know make a
lot of money as a music teacher but you
do get a certain kind of rich very rich